the judge has set the trial date for
Donald Trump in the federal case March
4th the day before super Tuesday
inhibiting Donald Trump's ability to
campaign on the most important primary
day of the election year this is overt
cheating in the 2024 election this judge
is anti-trump she'd already said that
she's surprised he's even free
considering what's going on so we know
where this is going they are pulling out
all of the stops and I think one of the
most damning things to come out from the
story of Trump's indictment in Georgia
is that the only person to be remanded
to custody is the black guy who runs
black voices for Trump we have a poll
that came out from Fox News that says
Donald Trump has 20 percent support
among black voters now if that's true
and it's a very big if because you know
among the I'd like to see this poll
repeated a hundred times before I
believe it but if that's true according
to the Wall Street Journal and many
analysts if the Republican Party reaches
20 percent support among the black vote
Democrats cannot win